getting ready to go for the giants mike
is the right-hander kevin gausman
kevin gausman 24-star 11-5 with the
2-2-9 era has had a little bit of
inconsistency with his split finger
fastball although the last couple starts
better and then they report that his
side
on the mound between starts this last
three days ago 2-2 pitch conforto
strikes out swinging and that was a real
good splitter you can't throw a better
one than that and that's exactly what
andrew bailey the giants pitching coach
was hoping he'd see early on in this
game 2-2 smith to left field darren ruff
circling in
and he makes a catch for out number
three
well it wasn't totally easy for kevin
gausman but he gets through it now
slater brian posey coming up
and they will face the lefty veteran
rich hill who's making his fourth start
fifth appearance with the mets
41 year old left-hander 6-5 220 pounds
out of boston massachusetts in his 11th
year or twelfth year at the big league
level
and six and four the four zero five era
tells you his year but
look at the strikeouts 103 against 43 uh
walks 113 innings and for a 41 year old
guy tells you he's still got great stuff
and he paints the outside corner for
strike three call three fastballs from
hill slater took them all
and he takes a u-turn
j.d six for 17 on the home stand just
completed and he lines one the other way
to right field brian will have to play
it on the hop and the mets have their
first base in the game a one out single
for j.d davis
jd davis at first one out
another o2 pitch
strike three swinging
now he's starting to elevate that
fastball with consistency and that's a
good strikeout pitch for him
got him with the splitter
so gusman gets a couple of strikeouts in
the second gave up a hit no runs still a
nothing nothing ball game
two and two the count and there it is
the one you were talking about mike
strike three he's as nasty as he's got
right that's five strikeouts and they're
all swinging miss strike threes
let's hit the other way and another base
hit for jd
two at bats
two balls hit the other way two base
hits for jd davis
right by him
the high hard one strike three six
strikeouts now six swinging miss strike
three strikeouts
and mccann lines one into center field
for a base hit davis pulls in at second
he'll stop there as slater gets it in
so a two out hit for can to keep the
line moving there's the splitter and
there's the strikeout
three strikeouts in the inning seven in
the game
bryant posey rough coming up
[Applause]
that one has hit hard into the gap left
center field toward 399
to the wall and it hangs in under the
wall there limo had to go and dig it out
a double for buster posey now darren
ruff
this is the first time the giants have
had a runner into scoring position in
this game line drive base hit left field
close he's going to be weighed by lotus
here comes the high arching throw it's
not off and back to first is
rough one nothing giants
mets meanwhile are contending that
they thought ruff did not make it back
to first base
so they have challenged this call we've
got a replay review he stepped on
alonzo's foot so he wasn't on the bag
but did the heel of the other foot come
down in the bag
before the tag was made so he stepped
right on top of pete's foot
but then the other foot came over and
hit the bag at some point the question
is whether it was before the tag
see now is any part of his foot on the
back no it's up but then the other foot
comes down does the heel the left heel
hit the back the left heel is way past
the back yeah you're right it's way past
i think he's out yes
that would be a very unusual call i'm
not sure i've ever seen anything quite
like that before
so the play will go 7-5-3 retiring rough
for the second half what a strange play
had a great heads up by the mets to
catch that on replay challenge the call
and roth is out
so two dad bases empty a run in
longoria right to second base where
nobody is based in
and that was by design going to crawford
he throws the over the top curve is
pulled into right field base hit
mongoria to second he'll stop there
up of the ball
conforto and he throws it back in
quickly so brandon crawford gets the
fourth straight hit for the giants now
you really start to think man that out
on the bases with the replay review
that's feeling pretty big right now
longoria's single crawford single
two on two out
left center field
that gets down for a base hit
longoria scores crawford to third the
throw cut off
by vr the shortstop
two nothing giants their fifth
consecutive head
that's pulled to right
great diving stop by la stella had
trouble getting it out of his glove and
nemo is able to beat it out
a fantastic play by le stella to get to
that ball in the shift
and so the tying runs on base with
alonso coming up
that's live the other way a base hit for
alonso that'll go to the gap and it'll
roll all the way back to the warning
track and to score his nemo conforto has
waved home pete's going to try for three
relay by le stella not in time it's a
triple for pete alonso to tie the game
alonzo comes through with runners in
scoring position and he drives one to
triples alley and picks up his first
three base hit of the year to tie the
game
three and two to smith with mcneil on
deck
and dom pops one up
in the left field tagging at third rough
with the catch alonzo is coming here
comes rough throw to the plate it's not
in time and the mets have the lead
[Applause]
that ball is hammered
deep right field it is
off the pillar between the fourth and
fifth archways slipping was conforto and
his throw is right there but too late
face it could tie the game
two and one the count
hit well to center field nemo back still
going back and
goodbye over the center field wall and
the giants jump back ahead
chris bryant goes deep
belts had a quiet few days came off the
injured list and just exploded it's that
one hard to center field
nemo going back all the way back gets
gone
pitch hit home run brandon bell
that's not quiet his 16th of the year
five to three giants
just the beautiful branded belt swing
there now chris bryant who he launches
one deep left
giants go back to back chris bryant his
second of the night on the very next
pitch 6-3
third giants home run for chris bryant
first multi-home run game in a giants
uniform and now jonathan villar who had
a base hit and stole a base in the sixth
and that's hitting the air in a deep
right field back toward the levi's
landing and it's out of here a home run
for jonathan vr
and it's now 7-5 san francisco giants
need a win to stay four up in the
national league west one out away
bounce toward third nice pick by
longoria steps it over to first in time
and this game is over the giants take
game one
against the mets